I'm here today to tell everybody how
much I'm going to to those paths once
i'm going to allows my daughter we going
through a lot
we cry every day you can speak
me and my family yeah it's not at all
notice Polly things that idea I'm here
because I had people call me a lot of
badness hell added but I had a lot of
things bad things people calling me
that's why I had to be there and let
people know a lot of things today this a
barn is no proof these past two months
like I say I'm going to a ladder I was
time my daughter was time but one day my
daughter told me she was mad please
promise me you're gonna use you sub kind
people to call you bad names people tell
bad things about you because they don't
know you you have to remember this guy
is a powerful man everybody knows that
but for you only the people that you
work with for our neighbors or the
people back home knows you but those
people say good things about you because
they know you please man stop crying be
strong for me they I promise I I'm going
to be strong for you and for every or
the woman underworld I don't what
happened to me I don't want that to
happen to any for the woman because
this is just too much for me is too much
for me and my daughter and